didn't you and rod wave have a little
weird moment online oh my god yeah we
definitely had a weird moment i was
trying like i hit him up a few times
once i'm like yo i'm [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] you feel me like
right on his page type [ __ ] dm'd him he
he i guess he ain't see it you feel me
but
then i like posted like a little video
of me like singing one of his songs and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] kind of went viral like i
took that [ __ ] down though because i was
feeling like like i was just doing
something like
doing too much you feel me like right
this [ __ ] ain't really like [ __ ]
with me like that right
but anyway lauren's pretty sure he had
post assumptions on there now he went
crazy everybody was like you don't
[ __ ] come to florida so he said some
wild [ __ ] i was like jesus christ that
escalated quickly so yeah i'm like hold
up i posted some [ __ ] on my instagram
and said like i'm so sick of this new
type of music like all this sad [ __ ]
y'all making me like too depressed right
now you know what i'm saying like i want
y'all to turn me back up you feel me
like
[ __ ] very general statement that's a
general statement yeah i ain't saying no
need someone i'll put an address on that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like hold up bro
[Music]
what's the word
you had some words and [ __ ] before me
and then he went on the internet again
and said some [ __ ] i'm like what are
they gonna do she must be trolling me or
something like the [ __ ] like
we already said what we had to say
already yeah you guys talk privately and
dm yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] my brain up and
i'm like this [ __ ] must be trying to go
viral i guess this is mine
young dude [ __ ] too man
you know i feel like you know maybe at a
certain point in time in your life you
were in that mentality you know what i'm
saying i never really think about the
viral [ __ ] like i'm even that i just
mean just like i think a lot of people
when we're younger we just react
it effects without thinking because we
haven't we haven't lived enough life to
realize that's not how
you know in the same way that you're
like man i've dm someone now you know
what i'm saying but like as opposed to
like a 20 year old kid who's uh barely
getting famous yeah absolutely just take
[ __ ] it just went left it just went left
like bro i didn't say your name
like what the [ __ ] are we talking about
like